all right Haley it is so good to see you
uh before we begin though I guess I have
to say congratulations on winning gold
that is huge how you feeling
like speechless you know every time you
wanna go like there's just there's no
words to describe the emotions and and
it's kind of like a high that you chase
over and over again so I guess you know
on to the next one yeah okay so with
like chasing that high right does it
ever feel as good as the first one do
they start to feel better
no the first one I was so emotional like
when they played the national anthem
like just Tears like flew down like I
was just like sobbing and I was like I
just it's just so incredible and I think
like especially when you share it with
like your teammates that you've bonded
with for months at that point in a
different country like basketball every
day like it's just a different it's a
different type of
of like celebration and I've the first
one is the best one but this was my
first like women's like women's event so
it felt different because I was like wow
like I just want a grown woman like gold
medal like these are grown woman so like
I was like this that big one yes
I love that so much well I mean so many
good moments and good videos uh came out
of those moments uh one that I was just
watching was video of you just breaking
your opponent's ankles and I'd bring
that up because I hear you literally
broke someone's ankles when you were
much younger can you please tell me that
story
it's actually funny because he my
brother literally brought this up to me
like two days ago and he was like can
you stop telling this story like I was
like
it's the best story
no my brother love him to death my best
friend on this whole planet but yeah we
played one-on-one when I was like
really I was like first or second grade
he was like fourth fifth grade and you
know he was in a boot after so that's
all that's all I'm gonna leave it at you
know my first victim so
like your first victim so whatever you
did you crossed them up so bad that he
ended up in a boot later is what you're
saying yes he he argues that it was his
toe like he broke his toe but I'm it was
ankle it was definitely ankle the extra
we have the x-rays to prove it so I I
have evidence so you have you can always
say oh no I have truly broken something
we all just talk about it yeah
absolutely I love it you know I want to
talk about young Haley a little bit more
because I know that when you were in
high school at one point you had said I
could have 20 points at halftime and
they'll still be chanting overrated have
you seen people's attitude towards your
game change or is there still a hint of
that that you feel
um you know I think
the attitudes to my game probably
haven't changed I think whether I care
what they think is has what has changed
you know as I've grown up like I have
learned that like it's just it's none of
my business what people think about my
game and I don't I don't have to prove
anything to anyone and I think that's
the only part that has changed and I've
ever since I've made that mindset switch
like I've played so much more free with
so much more joy and like just pure love
for the game so I wouldn't go back for
anything
I love that because you know I always
say it's not that people will ever start
treating you better or talking about you
better it's that you get better and as
you get better all of that stuff just
kind of works out in the ways that you
want it to so when was that moment for
you where you made that switch from
caring to not caring as much
you know like
it I think it's happened like several
times in my life but and you just kind
of like go back into your old ways you
know like when in between my freshman
and sophomore year of college like I
kind of like
was like okay I need to make a change
mentally because like I'm starting to
feel drained like caring and trying to
please everybody and wondering if people
think I'm good or not like and that was
when I first was like okay this is an
issue I have like I care too much and
then like I did good for a couple months
and then like went right back to it like
was worried what the aunt like the
analysts were saying about me where I
was projected in this and this and like
I just fell back into it but I really
think this summer uh I've done a lot of
work on it and like self-reflection
and I've I've been able to carry it
through like I carried it through this
world cup and and like people feel away
about like how we celebrated and people
feel away about my like decision to go
to LSU and like I can truly say like I
have peace in knowing that I don't owe
explanations to anybody for how I am my
personality like my decisions like
people are gonna feel the way they're
gonna feel and that's out of my control
and the only thing I can control is is
how I choose to feel about myself and so
like that's I've been really proud of
myself that I've been able to like
you know keep that mindset steady like
because it's easy to adopt it for a
month or so and then you kind of like go
back to the old Haley but I can say like
confidently now like I'm very consistent
in how I show up for myself every day
I love that and I'm so happy that you
feel like you know you have gotten to
that place you mentioned self-reflection
what does that look like for you what
are the questions you're asking yourself
in those moments
yeah I think you know like the major one
for me is like I come off as such a
confident person like I'm such a
confident personality you know but at
the end of the day when I was realizing
that I cared so much about what people
had to say like if they thought I was an
elite shooter if they thought I could
play defense like I was like is that
what a confident person would feel like
what a truly confident person like
really care and that's when I was like
okay I give off this Persona then I'm
super confident but I clearly like on
the inside that might not be who I am
yet and I gave myself Grace I was like
that's okay but the the first step is
like you know realizing that maybe
that's just a Persona that I give off
and I and I'm not truly confident deep
down and once I was able to like
discover that about myself and accept
that and be like that's okay we can work
on that like I've just I've made like
leaps and sounds and and life is just so
much more peaceful like that's that's
the most part like just life is peaceful
I'm happy I'm joyful
um like the world just brings things to
you
um that you want when you're in and when
you're in a positive headspace so
absolutely and that's so interesting too
because it kind of speaks to this idea
that a lot of the times what people
maybe think of us it's not that we
aren't that but we maybe aren't that yet
and so you're feeling like you're having
to catch up to the Persona that's out
there about about you while also trying
to become that person and you are also
doing it in front of so many people
figuring out who you are so I'm really
happy that you feel you you have reached
uh that peace and that Clarity uh within
your life because I think that's really
important it's going off of that I think
life is moving really quickly for you
how are you staying just sane generally
I know um you know I've been like
focusing a lot on just being in the
present and like I feel like especially
when we were trying to win the gold
medal in Europe and and it's so easy to
like look ahead to like oh we're gonna
match up with this team eventually like
you just like I just want to win the
gold medal already like you get anxious
for the future and like then I was like
I'm not really enjoying this like
wonderful moment that I have with these
three other girls that I might never
play with again in this like beautiful
country like I just you just don't get
to enjoy life as much when you're living
in the past in the future and so I think
um you know I was able to like really
Center myself and take it day by day and
um you know I came out of that
experience like having had so much fun
so I think like that's something that
I'm gonna try
um you know life is moving super fast
I've got a ton of new phases in my life
that I'm about to enter but the only
thing that I can do is to try to enjoy
all of it and truly take it all in is
like just be in the present you know I
feel absolutely any any living any other
uh in any other mindset it's just not
gonna allow me to really be where I need
to be
totally well I mean you know not to put
more pressure on you but what do you
want to mean to women's basketball
uh you know there's a lot of different
answers like I could give from like a
skills standpoint or like a an attitude
standpoint but I guess like
I hope that when young like boys and
girls watch me
um is that they kind of find security
that they can be who they are and that
their personality and who they are on
the inside like whether that shows in
sports or whether it shows like in the
classroom or wherever wherever they
choose to to like develop in life like
it's okay to be you like you don't have
to change and I think the people that
have impacted me most in my life like
that's what they've given me is like
it's okay to be Haley like God gifted
you these personality traits for a
reason like don't be scared and I think
like above all just be okay with who you
are because when you've when you find
that in life you know just good things
end up coming your way yeah so who
showed you that
um I think you know from the beginning
it's always been my family I've been
blessed with an amazing family my
parents my brother like they have always
supported me they always have my back
like they want me to be Haley and then I
think you know like as I developed in my
career and I was able to work with some
NBA players and WNBA players and like
you know I had my time with Kobe and I
I'm close with Kelsey Plum and and I've
talked to Kyrie and stuff like that and
all of them kind of give me the same
message as that like
it's okay to be who you are and like
they just have validated me in that
aspect and that not a lot of other
players that I look up to have and I
think like you know it just was
inspiring and so I've been inspired in
that way so I guess like I hope to
inspire other like young players in that
way too
that's great I mean and going off the
list you just named you have been able
to meet some really popular people in
Just Sports and culture whether that's I
don't know the people that you named
Jack Harlow Odell Kyrie so many people
which relationship or friendship has
been the coolest for you
um
you know
I will just talk about Jack Harlow for a
minute because
um you know he did a lot for
our my program at Louisville and the
team and the excitement around women's
basketball like he wore my jersey to a
festival and like it just like I feel
like he's really like bought into to
women's basketball and it's been cool to
um see him like invest in that way and
and be okay with like shedding some
light on us but no he's been super
awesome like I I just love like you know
whenever I get to see him or I've been
to a concert of his before and all that
and like you know I think
he's a great he's a great friend who's
just like
willing to give and I think a lot of
people you know all those personalities
and friendships that I have with other
like big stars a lot of people don't
always see that side of them and I think
it's just like it's cool for me me to be
able to genuinely experience that and be
like you know these are great people who
always want to give back and and help
build other people up
I love that and I will say so Jack is
one of my best friends and he is
genuinely a huge fan of you and he does
support women's basketball I remember
sitting watching the WNBA draft with
Jack and a lot of people won't sit and
watch that and he was so into it he has
his favorite players as he should so I'm
happy that you all have had a
relationship and you see just how much
he does care about sports in general but
specifically
um women's athletes I was reading that
your left leg is shorter than your right
leg how does that affect your game and
what accommodations you have to make for
that
no I mean I've had it ever since I was
little like I have a actual discrepancy
in my femur length on my left side
um and I used to like build up the
outside of my basketball shoe I got
three quarters of an inch and when I got
to college the doctors were like you
can't do this like you're gonna tear
yourself like this is just an injury
waiting to happen so I had to like
retrain my body to learn to play
um at the uneven lengths and like it was
a it was a ton of like Physical Therapy
a ton of like corrective
um stuff going on in my like skeletal
space and it was a lot of work and it's
still a lot of work you know I have to I
have to do it every day because it's a
problem I'm gonna have forever but
um yeah it's funny because like my whole
right side is bigger like my right calf
is bigger my white quad is bigger like
my right hand is bigger than my left
hand like literally everything on my
right side is bigger and I compensate a
lot on my right side like if people
watch my game when when I'm off balance
when I'm shooting I'm compensating on my
right side too much and so that's
something that I've I've learned about
myself and I know when my shot's off you
know watch the film look at look at
where you're Landing are you leaning on
your right side and so like you know I
know that about myself now so
um but it's it's something that you know
God gave me that I'm just gonna have to
work through every day do I wish my my
feet were the same length yes but at the
end of the day like I'm I still am what
I am with with what he gave me so
um it's just it's kind of a funny like
joke to tell people when they first sent
me like like it's like the Icebreaker in
the classroom like yeah my left leg is
shorter
yeah no for sure and then you know on
the upper part of your body do you like
being called the Lefty
I do like I love my Lefty I love my
Lefty Persona like I think it kind of is
like my Edge and it's funny to me
because like sometimes I get annoyed
because people are like oh like she's so
dominant left I'm like people that are
right-handed are dominant right like you
just started talking about me because
I'm left-handed like come on like it's
the same thing yeah yes like it goes
both ways bro come on but no I um I love
being left-handed and I think you know I
have that Lefty swag there's like a myth
that there's a lefty swag or whatever
but you know I think I have it so I
think yeah thank the Lord he blessed me
with the left hand because
because it came with some swag yes
exactly it wouldn't be the same if it
was the right for sure it wouldn't it
wouldn't as a as a right-handed person I
was saying the swag maybe would Elevate
if I was like that I don't know but I
don't want to do that to people you know
what I'm saying
um
your Twitter header has a quote that I
really like it says are you doing this
work to facilitate growth or to become
famous
what's your answer and why is that
message so important to you
yeah you know I think I stole that from
Kevin Durant but like it always just
like it was at a point in my life where
it hit me really hard and because I was
like starting to blow up and I felt like
um I felt like there was people around
me that had had changed their mindset
that maybe that this was something they
wanted to do to become famous and I
still felt like I love basketball like
at my core I'm not like a person like
I'm not like a social media personality
I'm a little bit more reserved like I'm
quieter like it's it's not something
that that I like would choose and I
think you know like there's pressure on
me to like be that social media
personality and I've just always went
back to that like are you playing
basketball to become great because
that's what I want to do I want to be
great at basketball I want to be one of
the greats
um am I trying to grow and be great
about basketball or am I continuing to
play basketball to set myself up for
other things like financially and and
like all of that and I think you know
for me I'm doing it to facilitate growth
because I have a lot of things that that
I want to do with my career that haven't
happened for me yet but yeah no I
definitely stole that from Kevin Durant
and I just it just like hit me I was
like you are right like this Society
growth like it was so true in that
moment and I just kept it there because
I feel like
you know when when sometimes when good
things happen like when I win the gold
medal like I've experienced success like
am I gonna change the reason that I
started playing basketball or am I going
to stay true to like that little girl
that just wanted to be great so
um
I love that and so when you saw KD say
that it hit you in a way that you were
kind of asking yourself or the things
that I'm doing equaling that
facilitating of growth and I think that
for honestly a lot of athletes it's easy
to get caught up in the being famous
aspect and the work kind of becomes
secondary so keeping the main thing the
main thing is really important have you
been able to tell KD that that message
resonated with you
um I actually haven't yet that's a good
idea though I should I should let him
know I you know I've corresponded with
him a little bit especially over this
last summer
um you know he congratulated me on my
commitment to LSU which which meant a
lot
um but no I think I think that would be
a good story because there are like he's
one of those people that I do look up to
in the fact that they seem very
disconnected from the the results that
come with being a star and that's what
he is like he he's clearly not in it
because he likes the way that it makes
him feel or the things that he gets or
the attention that he gets you know he
he doesn't give off that energy to me
and I think like that's something I
really respect about him for sure yeah
KD just wants to be great so I love that
you enjoyed that message
um one thing that I have really enjoyed
just recently really is the competitive
balance that we continue to see a
women's college basketball when I was
growing up and still now it's no shade
to UConn but it was like UConn was the
standard and it didn't matter you were
not going to be Yukon that was just what
it was whenever somebody talked about
that program how have you seen that
continue to change in college
yeah I think it was the same way for me
growing up like the only team I can
remember ever watching when I was little
was Uconn and like my more and like all
those great players and they they set
the precedent for women's basketball by
I think you know in today's climate
there's so many other schools that bring
like immense talent to the table and
it's so much fun for me to just be a
part of like I've been lucky enough to
come in a generation where we could
experience the growth of that right so
the ones before us kind of set the table
and broke the barriers in my generation
we still have barriers to break but
we're also kind of reaping the benefits
of all the hard work the players before
us
um did but no it's like it's something
so special I think like the women's NCAA
tournament this year was just crazy
because there was so much star power and
like you don't always see that a lot in
women's sports like there was like just
household names everywhere like
everybody knew who was playing in their
names and knew where they were from and
knew and knew their High School stats
like it was just awesome to it was just
really great to see the Game grow
because at the end of the day like
that's all I want like I want to see the
Game grow and I want to see more
opportunities be given to women and and
um you know the attention doesn't all
need to be on me because a win is a win
at the end of the day and if if my you
know teammates are getting attention or
another girl another team is getting
attention that's a win for the for the
game of women's basketball and women's
sports in general so I think it's just
been like
it's been very validating to see that
like people are starting to buy in and
and realize that you know the parody in
women's basketball is crazy now and and
you better come to play every day
because you could get Beats at home so
absolutely awesome any night could
belong to any team so I don't know if
this question is going to make sense but
if UConn you know was the Yukon of its
time who's the Yukon now what team what
program do you view is that oh I mean
honestly I feel like none because UConn
was so tall like yeah nobody's like you
know what I'm saying like I can't really
yeah I'm gonna
um I feel like the closest that since
I've been in college would have to be
South Carolina you know with how
dominant they were
um like they had a really great season
this last season they were obviously
national champions uh two seasons ago
like I think they're the closest that
we've seen
um but the game like we were just
talking about like the game is so strong
now that it's so hard for you to see a
back-to-back champion and like the die
like there's no really dynasties like
it's so hard to build a Dynasty now
because like
everybody has good players and so I
think yeah the closest I could say is
South Carolina but like realistically
like I don't think there's anybody
that's close to this yeah like UConn is
historically killing everybody like it's
it truly is wild
um but speaking of how hard it might be
to go back to back you have a tall task
ahead of you uh helping LSU potentially
do that so let's talk LSU I want to know
what did the first texts from Angel
Reese say
oh my gosh actually I hit her
um
as soon as uh as soon as they won in the
semis
um and after they won the National
Championship I hit her right away
because like I just loved her energy I
was like keep being you girl like do not
let anybody make you feel bad for being
who you are like you are a star and like
and she hit me back she's like I love
you Haley like gave me all the love back
and like it was great and then ever
since then you know we kept in contact
and uh I ended up choosing LSU but
um no I think I kind of reached out
first because I was like girl like I
love your energy like keep it up but no
she's been nothing but
um great to me supportive
um you know supporting me while I was
playing overseas for three on three like
um and she just seems like the type of
girl that wants other people around her
to do well and see them win and that's
that's what I respect and love about her
for sure I mean y'all are gonna have so
much energy on that team it is going to
be a show night in and night out so when
you look at this LSU Squad what do you
see
um you know
I think we there's a lot of personality
and a lot of people are are worried
about
um how it's gonna mix but I think at the
end of the day
um when you have the same goals and
that's to be the best that we can be as
a team that's not going to matter and I
think that I'm I'm with a bunch of girls
that are have that same goal and I don't
think we're going to have issues on that
front because we all just we want to see
the team do well and that's the vibe I
got from everybody and I loved it but I
also see like
I see a little bit of like a glimpse of
like a mini protein like it's kind of
like we've got so much we have so many
WNBA prospects and I really am excited
because I think it's going to give me a
taste of what the league is like and
playing on a team with with
um
such great players around me that like
how can I fit how can I help this scene
that is already so good like what what
can I do to help them and I think like
you know I'm very confident in what I
bring to the table but also I think it's
going to help me make it's gonna make me
so much better for the next stage of my
life which is the WNBA so
um
yeah I mean it's gonna we could probably
have a reality TV show next year I'm not
gonna lie it's gonna be all the Vibes
but
um I think it's just gonna be so much
fun to hoop with them like it's gonna
feel like you know like a summer like
summer Au like you're just there to to
have fun and ball out like I feel like
that's what it's gonna be like and I
just can't wait
so you said that you have been asking
yourself you know what can I do to make
this team good to make this team better
what answers have you come up with
um yeah I think I think I bring a
different type of leadership
um that I'll be able to help with
um you know I'm a little bit more of
like a calm a calm personality
um a different taste
um I think you know I I I do have point
guard skills a lot of people are like oh
she know the point guard all she does a
shoe and that's a lie okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna come here stand on two feet and
tell everybody right now that's a lie
um it's about what opportunity I've been
given and I think at LSU I'll be given
an opportunity to to play point and show
that I can run a team and so I'm very
capable of that and I also think I have
a unique shop making ability
um that kind of sets me apart so
um you know
I'm excited to show like that part to me
but I'm also just really excited for all
the ways that LSU is going to make me
better like I think defensively they're
gonna make me so much better I think
um you know from a leadership standpoint
they're gonna push me to be able to to
lead a team with other great players and
and I think there's just you know for as
much as I can do for them they can do so
much more for me so yeah you know as you
talk about your shop making ability that
was actually what stood out to me so
much watching the three on three and how
did you see that improve just while
playing in that World Cup
yeah I think you know a lot of people
wonder like why I chose three on three
this summer because I had the
opportunity to play for USA five on five
teams and I chose three on three and I
think like you said like you it just
pushes you to be better every single day
like you're gonna get exposed if you
have any weaknesses in three on three
you're forced to guard defense anything
yeah you you can't take no possessions
off baby or you're gonna be getting your
ankles snapped or someone's gonna be
dunking on you so no like it forces me
to become a better Defender it forces me
to become a better passer to become a
better reader to become a better shop
maker to finish new contact like I'm in
great shape like that's cardio to its
finest so like I think you know every
day we've lost our first game in the
tournament and I really watched the film
and I was like okay Haley like
how can I be better because we're trying
to win a gold medal and
um
luckily I was able to take that
information in and it translated well
every game after that and you know my
shots started going in thank the Lord so
um yeah I think
um just the immediate growth that I saw
in that tournament like really
reaffirmed why I chose to do three on
three in the first place because I think
it's such a great environment to to
improve
um yeah
no and and we could see that it was
really really fun to watch yeah you know
about three months ago I remember you
did an interview and you said that the
ACC was the toughest basketball
conference do you still feel that way or
has your mind changed oh well now that
I'm gone I don't know right you know
like Haley has left the building so yeah
it's a new game I don't know like
I don't know I think I think ACC and SCC
are are a little bit evenly matched I
think the star power and the SEC and the
the
um domination of certain players is a
little bit at a higher level but I think
overall like this the
um
evenly balanced like great teams in the
ACC is also something that's overlooked
like there's even the middle of the pack
teams are still really really good and
they do really well in the NCAA
tournament so I think like there's
certain things about ACC that are better
but there's also certain things about
SEC that are better I mean now that I'm
in the SEC I'm going to choose I'm going
to ride hard for the SEC as you see the
best Commerce in the country but I mean
if we're being honest like I think that
there's different attributes to both
that are have their benefits
totally okay well as we know we have
moved on to LSU we are in the SEC I want
to talk about Louisville really quickly
just because I know there are some
people that are probably still have some
questions about things so just broadly
what would you say is the number one
reason you decided to make the move
I think you know it
getting down to
my ability to be happy
um and I had to put myself first in that
instant you know I felt like I had done
my part and I had sacrificed myself and
given my all to that program and I was
very grateful for the experiences I had
there but at the end of the day I just I
wasn't Enjoying Everyday Life and you
know it's it's not necessarily all
Louisville's fault but it's also you
know not all my fault too so I think it
was a situation there where I chose that
I deserve happiness like I deserve an
opportunity to love life and
um that was why I left I had no idea
where I was gonna go I was fresh in the
portal like what am I going to do with
my life now but you know it was a really
emotional it was really hard decision
you know I I my best friends in my whole
life I made out Louisville
um I've went to a final four and I
shared that with those coaches and those
teammates and in some of the highs in my
life have been there but also the the
deepest lows of my life have been there
and I think that
um
I think that I was at the point where I
felt like I had learned what I needed to
learn from that situation in that
environment and I was giving myself
Grace to to leave that and find
something better for myself and
um you know
yeah I think I think a lot of people
speculate as to why I left but that's
exactly what they're doing is
speculating because they have no idea
what actually what actually happened or
transpired and I haven't ever really
given an explanation because like I said
earlier like you know I can't control
what other people are gonna say but I
know in my heart that I I made the right
decision for me and my family and and
for women's basketball in general so
um
yeah I think on both sides there's love
and appreciation
um for the time that we had together
because I don't regret it I don't regret
going to Louisville it made me I'm a
such I'm a much better player and a much
better person
um because of my experience there but
you know like I said I've given myself
the grace and the opportunity to to find
something better
good no I'm glad you're able to have the
space to say that because it sounds like
for you mentally you had to make that
move I don't know if most people think
that it was something that you had to do
for your happiness would you yeah
yeah I think you know with with nil
being a popular topic of conversation
and even like the ring chasing rumors I
think uh I think you know those are
logical things for people who don't know
the situation to attract to for
explanation as to why it happened but
it's it's definitely it's
it was a it was a decision made from the
standpoint of is Hayley happy and can
Haley attain happiness in this situation
and that's where I made my decision off
of and I think you know like I don't
feel bad for it
um because at the end of the day I had
to choose myself and and I was ready to
do that
good okay and most importantly do you
feel happy now
I do I do feel happy and I think like
I've grown so much even this summer and
and I've experienced I've I've had all
these experience that I never would have
had if I wouldn't have made the move
that I made and I think I've been able
to impact certain people with my
decision too like you know I think some
players are they do feel weight in in
pressure to stay at schools that they
might not be happy at
um because they don't want to disappoint
or they don't want to seem disloyal but
I think you know the only person that
you owe true loyalty to is yourself and
I think that I hope that other players
who were in my situation who truly feel
like they've got the most they could out
of of where they were and and
um that they weren't just truly happy
with who they were in that situation
that they give themselves the the
freedom to to go try something new
but I mean that's great perspective to
have um I'm not going to ask you about
specifics because I feel like you are
not ready to discuss that you just have
to promise me that whenever you do want
to talk about what happened you come to
me
also too was there any other schools you
were debating you know once you entered
the transfer Porter you're figuring it
out or was LSU the one do you have any
other options
um LSU was my only official visit
um you know I did I did talk to a few
other schools like I was entertaining
Stanford and in South Carolina but
um you know I felt like
my my relationship with Kim that I had
previously and
um
just the situation that that school was
in I felt like I was at a point in my
life where I was ready to take that on
and
um you know I think that's why I said
like I don't regret Louisville because
it turned me into the woman who I needed
to be to be able to to take LSU head on
and and do what is right with this
opportunity so
um yeah I think it's just a good fit on
all ends
um and it's gonna make me better it's
gonna prepare me for the league and
that's what's what was the main motive
for sure I will say there's going to be
some very sad South Carolina and
Stanford fans in the year they could
have met you on the team of no that
that's great I want to talk Kim Mulkey a
little bit because I just love seeing
her outfits on the sidelines she is like
such a good coach and always dressed
impeccably with her jackets how would
you style Kim Mulkey if you could style
her oh you know I do love like I do love
her little girl boss like pantsuits
um and the pops of color you know I
would I would probably add like a nice
bag because I feel like she never has a
bag like I would probably get like you
know some designer bags some designer
shoes just to like pop off but I don't
know I'm more of like a street style
girl too so like maybe I can convince
her to like wear a little tracksuit one
of these days
um but
I have no idea she you know her value
for my first game
right I should have put that in the
contract I should have put that in the
scholarship
totally I love it
um last little section for you I love
the video that is going around right now
of when you had broke the gold medal but
you're holding in you're like doesn't
matter I'm the best I want to
contextualize what you mean in in that
moment to you what do you feel you are
the best at
um you know I felt when I said that in
the moment it was like we're the best in
the world like I'm a world champion like
my team were world champions were the
best
um but I thought I feel like you know
like now that I'm what like when I watch
the video it's hilarious actually like
it's so funny but
um like I truly was just
so happy in that moment and I felt so
confident in who I was that like I do I
do think I'm the best and that's okay
it's okay it's okay to believe in
yourself and I feel like sometimes
especially as a female athlete we can be
like put people put shame and Gail on us
when we're actually have self-confidence
and are like no I deserve this moment I
deserve this spot and I just you know
I'm not gonna shy away from that like I
am I am confident I do think I'm a
really good basketball player do I think
I need to get better 100 do I think
there are other great basketball players
that I admire and think they're gonna do
great things for the game 100 but
there's space for all of those things
there's space for everyone at the table
everyone can eat right so I'm gonna give
myself my space I'm gonna sit down at
the table and eat too yeah and I think
that
um you know I don't like I just am
Unapologetic about it and and
that's where the peace in life has came
in like I I'm gonna be me and that's
okay
no it is bringing me
so much joy to hear you say that because
I was actually just talking about this
like last summer I had interviewed Jason
Tatum and in the interview we're talking
about what it's like when he would show
up to pro-ams and he goes you know I
think I'm a big deal and he said it so
casually and with so much conviction
saying that he felt like he was one of
the best and that he was a big deal and
I'm like women should be able to say
that exact same thing because male
athletes talk about being the best being
the goat being the king all these things
all of the time and nobody really bats
an eye but if you're good at something
if you're one of the best at your craft
you should be able to say that because
you feel it to be fact so why do you
think it's important for women to
continue to outwardly express the things
that they're really good at
yeah I think you know like you said like
I think in the in these playoffs like
Jimmy Butler was like I'm the best
player in the world
and that's okay like I love that for you
Jimmy like I love that I love that
energy but also when a woman does it
like don't come at us sideways and I
think that
um you know I think that my teammate
Angel Reese is is a great vehicle
um for that type of energy and I just
can't wait to support her and back her
but I think like you know it's gonna the
game is gonna change when women feel
comfortable in their sport in their
Arena to actually say how they feel
about themselves and not always feel
like oh being confident is unladylike
like talking trash is unladylike no all
these things are are a part of sports
and it's what people love about sports
and I think that you know I'm not scared
to to
say those things about myself like do I
I think I'm the best because I know that
people that are truly confident and are
at my level of of self-security aren't
going to take that as a threat they're
going to take that as an invitation to
be around someone who who is in the same
headspace as them and I think that
that's why I've been okay with saying it
lately because I'm in that space where
if someone said that to me I'd be like
you right girl like you are hard I want
to play with you like that was how I
would respond because you know like
Cameron Brink won the MVP of the three
on three tournament and like I was
ecstatic for her because she did she
played great does that mean that I
didn't play good just because she played
great no I still had a great tournament
too like I said there's room for
everyone at the table and I like I just
feel like now that we're in a place
where young girls in college it's like
there's always been the older WNBA
players who have kind of pushed the
boundaries but now like there's this
Avenue for these young college players
to really Express themselves and and
show self-confidence I think I think
we're going to see another level reach
in women's basketball and women's sports
in general as as this kind of comes to
life a little bit
for sure I mean and you have no shortage
of confidence on the court you seem to
be a very good trash talker would you
agree
I do I think it's one of my strong skill
sets like if you're gonna list pros and
cons like the number one pro of Haley
van lith is trash talking
what is like what is the key to like a
good dig on the court
um oh
I think you know like kind of being calm
about it is like like you don't need to
scream in their face like when you say
it calmly I feel like it's much more
intimidating like if I can just look you
dead in your eye and tell you that I
just gave you a bucket without screaming
like you're gonna take that personally
and I feel like that's that's my
strength is I can I can trash talk and
be like in a normal like level of voice
like I don't have to scream at you like
yeah we can have a conversation it's
like this is what happened like deal
with it yes 100 okay so from just what
you've gathered up to this point who
seems to be the best trash talker on LSU
oh oh my gosh I mean I'ma let Angel
Reese have her crown right right yes
it's her moment she's definitely braver
than me like she she has no like she
does not care and I love that for her
and I can't wait to be laughing on the
court next to her when she's doing it
but no I think I think she's the queen
I'm gonna give it to her you know like
she deserves it yeah something that's
really so great about watching you and
an angel as well is it's clear that you
all have had coaches in your life that
have nurtured that personality like they
have allowed you to be emotional is that
accurate yeah 100 yeah and how does that
help you because I think sometimes
you'll see coaches that have a player
you know that is passionate that is
fiery and they maybe think they have to
reel that in whereas for you that
passion is what makes you a really good
basketball player
yeah I think
um
you know
like a coach and play a relationship is
something that a lot of people
undervalue and I think as a player for
me when I feel like seen and recognized
and valued by my coach like my potential
just goes skyrockets and when I feel
comfortable in who I am as a person and
I feel like my coach accepts me for that
like my potential is going to Skyrocket
the limit is is going to increase and
um you know I've had coaches through all
levels that have I've been blessed with
with a lot of coaches that have um
affirmed me and let me be myself you
know probably the the best one that
comes to mind is my dad like
um you know he was my trainer my whole
life you know everything that you see on
the court he made right he made in the
gym with me when I was
seven working out that attitude that I
have like he he showed me that it's okay
to do that and
um yeah like I think when
when you're encouraged by the people in
your circle that
um
however you feel like express it and be
Unapologetic about it you know there's a
way to be respectful 100 yeah and I've
been raised to be very respectful so
there's no issue in that but I think you
know I just
um I've been blessed with people in my
circle who are just cool with me being
Haley and
um you know not all players are are
blessed with that and I think that
um that's something that I can help
share with the world
I love that for you I love it um okay
well last thing just speaking of trash
talking you know I have to talk about
this because it was such a big moment
just in basketball generally
so when Caitlin Clark did the you can't
see me gesture it was against Louisville
yeah and it looked like it was directed
towards you walk me through it from your
Vantage Point with Caitlyn Clark it was
actually hilarious because at right
after the game I texted her and I was
like the media is dumb I'm sorry like
you guys have no like they just make
stuff up and then they just put it all
over the Internet and everyone thinks
it's true like it's just hilarious we
were laughing about it because she
didn't she did it to her strength coach
like she didn't do it to anyone on our
team especially me like definitely not
towards me she did it to her strength
coach and it wasn't even in a moment
where I didn't even see it in the game I
was probably you know dribbling the ball
at the core after she just hit a three
in our face so
um you know like it's just funny how
like camera angles and and perceptions
are skewed through the media but it was
just it was hilarious we laughed about
it oh my gosh I don't even remember like
she I didn't even see it happen so my
perception like I don't even have one
because I didn't even know what happened
until I saw it over Instagram later no I
can't so is this the first time you're
being asked if it was to you
I mean in person yeah like people have
speculated and like you know said it on
social media like does Haley like was it
to Haley and I've just never answered
because like who cares but like yeah no
like this is my first time so I'm
clearing it up guys Kaelyn Clark did not
do this to me and if she did that would
have been hilarious and we would have
laughed about it too like it's not that
serious no I love I love getting this
context it's important so I love but I
love also what that gesture ended up
meaning like it was just such a moment
and I love you know women's basketball
should have these moments you know it
should be about what happens on the
court it should be about personalities
at some at times it should be about
drama like that's what makes Sports fun
so so many of you have just continued to
make this sport everything that we love
so it has been such a joy uh to watch
you I can't wait to watch you at LSU so
last one for you just what do you want
to prove uh to probably yourself this
season
um you know I think
I it's a loaded question because I'm
like what do I want to prove to myself
and I think like
what I've been focusing on lately is
like everything I need and and
everything I want to have I already have
it I already have it it's just up to me
whether I believe that I have it and um
you know that it's that's actually a
scripture that I've been studying a lot
out of the Bible is like before before
you ask you have to believe that you
have received it to have received it and
I think that
um you know
giving myself space to be like okay if
this is what I want I already have it in
me so how do I bring that how do I bring
it out of me right now because it's
already in me the player that I want to
be is already inside Haley like how how
do I allow myself to let it shine and I
think like you know that's what I'm
trying to prove to myself is like I have
it all in me like Haley just gotta
figure out how to bring it out like
gotta figure out how to channel it so
yeah well you go and receive all those
things I am rooting for you hopefully I
can see you when I am in New Orleans if
y'all have a game I'm gonna go to Baton
Rouge I'm gonna come watch I love
watching angel love watching you so
thanks so much for your time you're
fantastic no thank you
foreign
[Music]